[Music]
let's go to shantae in philadelphia
what's up shantae how are you doing
good how are you dr liloni good were you
born and raised in the playgrounds where
you spent most of your days oh my gosh
that's okay yes i was
very cool all right so what's up how can
i help
so i feel a little guilty about making
this call
last night um i was i was gonna call you
about like how like horrible my marriage
has been but like last night my husband
like
tried to make amends of me he hugged me
kissed me told me a lot of the times he
was overreacting was through the
childhood trauma and that we're going to
be all right
we just got to keep working at it but um
i'm still going to go ahead with my
question i'm just a little guilty and
apprehensive now
um so my issue is how do you make a
marriage work
like when it's been in turmoil for
months and it's just exhausting and
draining and it seemed like you're both
like always on different paths
even though like
it's to reach the same common goal it
just seems like you're always in a
different world
number one thank you for being brave and
you're welcome to feel guilty it's your
right to feel guilty i hope you won't
okay
one night of
basic human emotion one one evening of
basic
fidelity if you would like emotional
fidelity being honest with you
um doesn't make up for months if not
years of
um
instability okay and so i don't want you
to feel guilty
um
can i tell you something honest
yeah last night based on your question
just now last night feels more like a
move than an honest reflective things
got to change around here am i wrong i'm
happy i would love to be wrong
that feels like a narcissist you know i
hate if you listen to the show i hate
saying the word narcissist
because i have no business diagnosing
anybody so i don't mean that diagnostic
terms but
that's a classic narcissist move
which is
beat up beat up beat up blame you
gaslights you for like well you're just
overreacting why are you so mad you
should be lucky to have me and then
there's the i'm so sorry baby
i had some stuff happen to me it's not
my fault it happened to me and i'm gonna
fix it and then it goes right back
tell me i'm wrong please i'd love to be
wrong
i was thinking did he get a hold of my
email or something no i hadn't seen your
email
no like my husband i'm thinking did you
see i was coming on the show soon and
just decided to throw in the red flag
but i'm like no he didn't he has like
different passwords so yeah it did seem
odd like the time and it was like i've
been waiting for months for this and it
just right before like last night
literally before i was supposed to wake
up and take this far so i don't know
okay i'm gonna flip things around on you
okay okay to answer your question
you don't
you cannot make a relationship work when
everybody's on the same on different
pages
when you have secrets from each other
you gotta hide stuff from one another i
don't tell him that stuff because that
sets him off i got these passwords
because i can't trust him with this i
don't want him seeing that it doesn't
work
period
um
you have to to make this thing work
beyond the same page
um when you said i've been waiting for
this for months
if nothing else on this call i want you
to hear me say
never ever wait again
you're worth more than that
shantae and what i mean by that is
just waiting for somebody to quote
unquote figure it out or come around
is that's how you end up and also in a
decades gone by and you have two kids
and another one on the way and you're
like who am i and what happened and i
wanted to be a doctor and now i'm
working part-time you know what i mean
your life just slips through your
fingers while you're waiting on somebody
else to meet your needs that that you
didn't speak out loud
and so hear me say as firmly as i can
you are worth your needs being spoken
out loud
and you may have never even seen that
you don't have a picture of what that
even looks like in your mind so i'll
give you one
that looks like
he goes off on you he's angry
and you say i'm gonna stop us right now
you or anybody will not talk to me in a
disrespectful tone
you will treat me with respect i'm gonna
step out
and i'm gonna go for a walk around the
block and i'll be back in a minute and
we're gonna do this again later or
i'm gonna take a couple of days
and i'm gonna go stay with my mom and
then i'm gonna circle back and we'll
have this conversation when the smoke
clears here but this isn't gonna how
we're gonna interact i'm worth more than
this
that's what i'm talking about okay
yeah um and i know that's hard there's
economic concerns there's all kinds of
things that make that really challenging
um
tell me what happened last night
um
so last night we were just um laying
there and well he cooked dinner first
and then he was being playful with with
me which i really didn't know how to
respond because sometimes like
when i'm playful back it might turn into
something so i was just letting him do
his thing and he called him yeah hold on
it might turn into something like y'all
might end up sleeping together or am i
turning something like it ends up he
gets mad because it's not going like
because he's losing control because
you're playing along too
oh no we love even though we slept
together
but um
no it's more like i might say something
but he didn't find what i said to be
appropriate funny or now i'm not in the
mood to play anymore and you play too
much and
yeah
so like that okay
so i just let him you know do his thing
play um just chuckled a little bit
didn't say much and then um
we went to bed and then he hugged me
kissed me um told me that
sometimes his reaction is because you
know what he's been through because he's
traumatized from his childhood and that
we're going to be all right and we're
going to be okay um but just last week
before then he um
he walked past me after we had like a
disagreement on something that it was
small to me but i guess it was big to
him and he he threw his ring at me and
said we're separated and i'm like that's
not how separation works i mean we're
still living in the same house where he
said oh well you know well you've been
married before to know that he was being
sarcastic because this is like our first
marriage with each other like you can't
tell me how separation works
and um
so he took his ring off um
and
told me that he's been looking for rooms
and whatnot
in case if i basically if i do one more
thing to upset him
before june happens he's going to
go explore an option and rent a room
somewhere just to get some peace and
clarity because i don't bring him peace
and
and then so
it's been like real rocky but then last
night it just seemed to be real calm and
him throwing a like finally throwing
like a loop or a ring towards me when
it just seemed like we were going
completely like opposite ends so
so can i ask you um and i'm not asking
this in a disparaging way
are you hard to live with
um
maybe
no no shantae tell me the truth
are you hard to live with
i don't think so but being with him i
started to question am i
and um i don't think it's that i think
he because here's why i say that we both
work like i worked at nine five he does
as well
and sometimes like um he might not say
it but he'll expect me to do the
traditional full-on like house
duties while i'm still working so
sometimes i'll say hey what can you help
out or if i clean up can you just be
like
more aware not to just leave your stuff
around because when i'm coming when i
leave out for work and the house is
clean i would like to come into a clean
house first every single day having to
like keep cleaning the house because
he's kind of like
messy yeah so to speak he's not nasty
he's kind of messy and his thing is be
like you're the one when you pick it up
like basically i'm making him he doesn't
want me to control him
so man okay i think maybe in that case i
am but it's not like you can go like you
can he could be on his phone for hours i
won't bother him because i have my own
stuff going on so i didn't think i was
hard to live with
and i'm not like a smothering type i
don't smother it's like you can do your
own thing it's fine like it's not like
your own thing like that but like i'm
not constantly on you like
shantae you all are newlyweds in your
first year of marriage
yeah
this weekend is our one year
this should be
like i don't know oh my gosh
you're hiding in your own home and so is
he
and
i i i can't say anything negative about
him because he's not on the phone with
me okay
and so i'm gonna assume that after a
year
the whole house is just hard
right
yeah and i'm gonna i'm gonna choose to
say you know what
that guy had a moment of clarity
and he realizes he loves you
you're special
and he wants to do what he has to do to
make this thing work and he may have
never told anybody about childhood stuff
that happened and that was the first
time you spoke at all so i'm gonna go
down that road okay
so here's the next steps and i don't
know another option around these next
steps
you have two actually you have two paths
forward
path number one is this
and this ends at some point
okay
yeah path number two is this
you tell them
our one year anniversary is coming up
and before we go do something romantic
for our anniversary i want to have a
follow-up conversation on what we talked
about last night
and this isn't a spring it on him this
isn't uh he's watching tv and you go
turn the tv off this is
on friday i want to go out and i want us
to have a grown-up conversation we need
to have
and here's what that all that
conversation is is this
you said we're going to be okay
you said you've got some childhood
struggles that you're working through
you said you're sorry that and if you
have things to apologize for shantae
what you probably do say em say i'm out
loud okay
and
say
being okay moving forward looks like
this for me what does it look like for
you and you're gonna have to i would if
i'm you i'm writing this stuff down
it looks like i need help around the
house
we're both working i know there's some
traditional gender roles i need some
help here
i can't work a full-time job and then
come home and work a full-time job i
need some help
number two
don't ever throw your ring at me again
i need us to always know that no matter
how sideways things get our marriage is
okay that we're committed together
and if you tell them you're going to
look for rooms before you start looking
for rooms at least honor me enough to
say hey here's what i'm struggling with
in the house
and not wait till there's it's the door
shut you know what i mean and so
whatever those needs are for you
um
i need you to be more playful and sexual
with me i miss you
i need i want you to be really explicit
about your needs
and this is a low reactivity not gonna
fight
i'm not gonna argue i need you to listen
to all the things i'm gonna say and then
you listen and then i'll listen to all
things you're gonna say we're not gonna
lob grenades at each other
but we've got to make a plan for moving
forward and then here's the hard thing
us being okay means you're gonna have to
go talk to a counselor about your
childhood trauma that's what you got to
do
and i know that's not cool and it may
not because buddies may be that that's
what you're gonna have to go do if
you're serious about healing from that
stuff and
we'll i'll even go with you if you would
like but we're going to do this together
you see what i'm saying here's what i'm
trying to give you back shantae i'm
trying to give you your power back and i
want your husband to have his power back
and i want you all to have power
together and i want you to look at your
relationship apart from each other and
say let's make this thing really good
how can i help meet your needs and
here's my needs how can you help how can
i help you meet my needs see what i'm
saying but that yeah but that's the
thing i suggested counseling like
together and individually
one like a few weeks ago and then he
said that um he'll get there to the
counselor and say all the right things
and when he leaves that he's not
changing he's going to do his own thing
because he's stubborn and no one's
telling him how to live his life
but i also forgot to mention in the
email because i was just so overwhelmed
with my own emotions
that he he was being a therapist before
we got married but because he had um he
was diagnosed with ptsd and anxiety
um and he he was taking
like medicine for it but then he stopped
and like he he says off and on that like
he's gonna go back and he's gonna you
know but it's never no follow-through
then when i finally mentioned counseling
again he was like i'm not you know those
people they're just working a job you
know when they leave they do what they
want when i leave i'm gonna do what i
want but you can waste your money if you
want to okay so
so here's the thing you can't control
him he's a grown man
the only person you can control and this
is hard is you
and right now you need somebody in your
corner on a regular basis i don't think
good therapy is a waste of money in fact
i think it is a lifeline for many many
of us millions and millions of us and i
do hear that a lot and i get that that
someone's just doing a job they're just
pushing paper and just pushing a broom
yeah i don't know therapists like that
the therapists i know deeply care about
people and
they want them to have peace in their
life and laughter and joy in their life
and good sex lives with their spouse
they want these things for them and so
this idea that they're just like getting
a job and clocking out it's not true
they're i'm sure they're therapists out
there i just don't know them
most there even the ones i disagree with
how they're doing it they really want
what's best for their clients so it's
not about i'm gonna tell you what to do
it's hey if you're coming to me and say
it's like going to the gym right the
trainers like what are your goals well i
want to get huge all right well here's
the workout plan for getting huge i
ain't doing that
okay
like it doesn't affect my workout if
that's your choice you make cool you
know what i mean so it's less about i'm
telling you what to do as a counselor
and it's more
hey you just explain this out here's the
path
towards changing your family tree
here's the path towards sleep and my
heart breaks for him
because it sounds like he had a rough go
of it as a kid is that true
yeah he did he opened up to some things
prior to the american during marriage
um
yeah it's a lot yeah
and so here's the deal
um
i'm gonna send you a copy he may not
read it you can read it you can leave it
laying around i'm gonna send you a copy
of my new book on your past change your
future okay
the whole premise of that book is we
have to look in the mirror and say this
stuff happened to us
it happened okay full stop
i got abused someone treated me wrong
because the color of my skin somebody
hurt me somebody beat me up so this
these things happen to me
and there's a period at the end of those
sentences some of them i'm still in an
abusive relationship i'm still being
treated differently because um a woman
in a workplace right whatever the thing
is
i have to look in the mirror and own
those stories
and then i have to ask myself that one
terrifying scary brave question
what am i going to do now
am i going to continue this cycle
or
am i going to take one or two years of
my life and it's gonna be hard and
brutal and challenging and i'm gonna
change
everything
right
yeah and he has to do that work you
can't do it for him
i'll tell you this he's lucky to have
you okay
why'd you marry
why'd you marry him
um
i always tell him that he's brilliant
like he's karen he's um like his heart
like once he gets an idea and you just
see him go like he gives it it's all
um he's protective and he's caring like
over like who he loves um
overall he does have a good heart it's
just
um
i just haven't been saying that lately
but
and he's funny he's nice he's kind he
has
goals and dreams for himself and not
selfishly like oh i just want this like
he cares about the children he he wants
he wants more and he's ambitious and
just him like you'll never meet like him
like wherever you are like you'll never
meet him
in him like he's a one of a kind
sounds like you love that guy
yeah and it sounds like you're all so
exhausted
yeah do you do you hate the fact that
the guy you love is hurting so bad
yes of course
okay
have you told him that
it's kind of hard i don't know like i
know
i don't know how to get like gauge him
sometimes okay
um where i've seen effective in the past
as people sometimes write letters
when somebody sits down and says hey
what you told me last night boom
if you're a trauma survivor
your walls go up immediately right then
i'm not hearing a word you're saying i'm
just trying to survive this conversation
and if i means at the end i have to just
brush you off if i have to pull out my
phone and act like i'm ignoring you if i
have to
be overly emotional and yell something i
will survive this conversation
what a letter does sometimes is it
allows that wall to come up and then it
goes back down because there's not the
person in that room and i can read it
again and then i can read it again and i
can read it again
and the second time i read that letter
the second and half time the third time
now i'm starting to hear it
not always sometimes people read it once
they throw it away in the trash they say
don't write that that's fine that
happens
but sometimes they read it again and
again and they start to go oh my gosh
that woman loves me
so here's my rule of thumb if you are
not safe
if you are worried about your
psychological or physical safety you got
to get out you promise me
of course okay
deeper than that
you are worthy of your needs and the
greatest gift you can give him is
telling him here's what my needs are and
it's going to come with a risk because
he might look at you and say i'm not
meeting those needs i'm out
and if he does that would be because he
chose to go not because your needs were
wrong
okay
you know
that's the only path forward for both of
you and if you the second thing you got
to ask him is and what are your needs
how can i help meet your needs
and how do we do these things together
okay and that's not me that means like
okay then i got another eight-hour shift
after i get home where i gotta re-roof
the house and mow the yard like that's
not what that means
but that means we're gonna have this
conversation together i need you to pick
up your clothes that's not too much of
an ask i need you to help with the
dishes that's not too much of an ask i
need you to give me an hour and a half
at night just to let me
have some breathing room cool i'm in for
that i need to just be able to go to the
gym cool i need to be able to cool well
we can make those things happen
i'd love to meet this guy sounds like
he's great
so like he's hurting a lot and he's
trying to figure things out
um i don't know if he's great i don't i
don't i haven't met him but it sounds
like he's hurting he sounds like he
loves you he's trying to figure it out
clarity clarity clarity and you need to
make the call and go see a counselor
okay that's the only person you can put
into counseling is yourself
please make that call because you're
worth it
you